COMMITTEE IS SO WAITING TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND WE'RE
WAITING FOR MR GAINES.
AND OR MR GLAZER.
WE HAVE ONE BILL ON THE AGENDA
IT'S THEIR BILL
.
STEPH IS PRESENTING FOR MISTER
GANSKE OKAY [inaudible]
I JUST.
NOW I KNOW WHY YOU HAD THAT LOOK
ON YOUR FACE YEAH I JUST GOT THE
WORD THAT YOU'RE PRESENTING FROM
MISTER GAINES.
LET LET'S GO AHEAD WERE STARTING
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
I MEAN MISTER.
I DON'T KNOW [inaudible]
I SEVERAL.
BILLS ON IT.
REYES ARE AVAILABLE.
NOW WE DALY CITY.
WE WE ARE.
WE ARE NOW ACTING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE WE HAVE SIX MEMBERS
INCLUDING ONE REPUBLICAN MEMBER.
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR.
WE NEED ONE MORE MEMBER TO HAVE
A QUORUM BUT PLEASE GO AHEAD
[inaudible]
THEIR GAZES [inaudible]
BOB HERE [inaudible]
PROGRAMS.
MIDDLE CLASS [inaudible]
TO SPECIAL [inaudible]
MEDI CAL [inaudible]
PROGRAM STANDARD [inaudible]
AFFORDABLE.
A FORTY EIGHT WE HAVE PEOPLE
STANDING.
OTHER THE MOTHER ANY QUESTIONS.
WE NEED ONE MORE MEMBER.
WE NEED MISTER QUINN DID MR
GRAYSON.
OR MISTER COOPER [inaudible]
MISTER MAYES MISTER HARPER.
IN THAT ORDER [inaudible]
ASK GRAYSON.
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND.
TO PROVE THIS BILL ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR WE OKAY
PROCEDURALLY.
I THINK WE HAVE TO CALL THE ROLL
HALL DO IT.
I'LL DO IT DAILY HERE
[inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
MISS CABALLERO [inaudible]
CALDERON HERE [inaudible]
MISTER GRAYSON [inaudible]
YOU'RE HERE [inaudible]
MISTER COOLEY [inaudible]
YOU'RE HERE.
WE'VE TAKEN A ROLE.
I JUST TOOK ROLE MARK.
AND A WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND WE'VE TAKEN ROLE.
AND I BELIEVE PROCEDURALLY WERE
OKAY MISTER LAWYER.
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE'VE HAD A
QUORUM FOR FIVE MINUTES
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
OKAY MOTION SECOND ROLL CALL
VOTE PLEASE.
POINT ARE THERE ANY PERSONS HERE
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
OTHER ANY PERSONS.
AGAINST THE BILL.
WE WILL PROCEED TO A ROLL CALL
VOTE AS SOON AS TRACY IS READY
FOR THE ROLL CALL [inaudible]
I I HELLO [inaudible]
HERE ARE [inaudible]
THERE IS [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
Q. [inaudible]
FRAZIER AYE.
GRAYSON I'VE GRAYSON AYE HARPER
AYE AYE PARKER AYE. EIGHT THE
BILL PASSES WITH AN EIGHT ZERO
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HEARINGS CLOSED
.
MOST OF HERTZBERG